Clearly the price of oil has had an
effect on the US economy,
but it hasn't been pronounced.
I think as many people feared.
Um,
I remember back in 2002 economists were
spreading over their possibility of 40
or $50 oil.
Well now we're at a hundred dollar oil.
A lot of people don't like it,
but most of us can still afford it.
Now.
It's definitely hurting a lot of people.
I'm not making light of that and it's
definitely a lot of people who drive a
lot truckers,
they're feeling a big pitch.
Um,
but oil at $120,
you know,
I don't know that it will be
substantially different from oil at 100.
Um,
uh,
the price of gasoline is going up.
But,
uh,
you know,
there are a lot of other factors now
that are coming into the price of crude,
um,
besides demand.
And that is the falling value of the
dollar.
And,
um,
uh,
a lot of speculators in the market now
affecting the price of crude.
So you know,
how much they increased price,
we'll have what effect it will have.
You know,
I can't predict that.
Well I think that,
you know,
theory anyway,
the $5 a gallon price is one that people
often mention as one where huge amounts
of conservation people drive,
we'll quit driving,
they'll carpool or ride their bikes.
Um,
I think that that makes some sense.
But for myself,
um,
I live in Austin,
I often have to drive to Houston.
Uh,
if my choices are taking the bus or
flying or driving myself,
I'm still gonna probably buy $5 a gallon
gasoline.
And I think that,
you know,
for,
as I recall about two thirds of the
transportation miles driven by
civilians,
non non commercial operators or people
driving to work.
So I think even at $5 a lot of people
are going to pay it because they have to
get to work.
So I think we haven't seen yet a price
high enough.
I think for,
uh,
a lot of societal changes overall in
terms of the end of the suburbs or so
on,
uh,
because,
we still see gasoline as a necessity.
And I think for many people that still
isn't,
will be for a long time to come.
Okay.